quand un accident de la vie devient une
force là encore l'incroyable histoire
maintenant de Cassandre Plessis victime
d'un AVC à 18 ans la loi richarienne
s'est relevée grâce à l'amour de ses
chevaux aujourd'hui influenceuse sur
Youtube et Instagram c'est vidéo sur
l'équitation sont suivis par des
dizaines de milliers d'abonnés la
Turquie la suivie
rêve compulsif c'est sous ce nom que
Cassandre se fait le plus souvent
reconnaître en 2014 elle se lance sur
Youtube pour parler de sa passion pour
les chevaux et s'appeler depuis deux ans
c'est son travail à temps plein plus de
180 000 abonnés sur sa chaîne et 120000
sur Instagram Cassandre touche un très
large public et ça n'est pas toujours
sans conséquence surtout les jeunes nous
prennent vraiment comme exemple et faut
faire très attention à ce qu'on dit et
ce qu'on monte sur les réseaux parce que
on est des exemples et il y a des fois
on a l'impression qu'on a pas le droit à
l'erreur que j'ai des choses à
transmettre à mes abonnés à ma
communauté mais eux aussi mon mandat
après une matinée de montage Cassandre
par s'occuper de ses trois chevaux et
c'est l'heure du pansage pour nomades
devant l'objectif de sa caméra c'est au
tour dyboy de ce dégourdir les sabots
accompagné d'Héloïse son ami et cadre
rose du jour aujourd'hui Cassandre monte
à cheval sans difficulté mais ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas il y a 10 ans elle
est victime d'une thrombose cérébrale un
vrai stop dans sa vie de jeune adulte
elle se raccroche donc à sa passion
l'équitation et c'est là que commence
l'aventure rêve compulsif du fait
d'avoir failli perdre la vie j'ai décidé
de vivre mes rêves donc c'est ma ligne
conduite en fait de vie aussi compulsif
mais réfléchi quand même soit-il on est
en vie et la vie elle est belle malgré
tout tous ses côtés sont Cassandre vit
maintenant de sa passion et continue à
délivrer son message plein d'espoir au
fil de ses vidéos